hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
the spatia temporal organization
dynamics and function of virus
replication centers
during marine polyomavirus infection
i'm alexis corrales of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lapperts
and sponsored by andorr for more
information about our sponsor
please visit their website at andor.com
now
let's get started i would like to remind
everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
dr doug peters
post doctoral research assistant bio
frontiers institute at the university of
colorado boulder
and dr alan mullen product specialist
for microscopy cameras at andor
technology
for a complete biography on both of our
presenters please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
dr peter you may now begin your
presentation
hi everybody thank you for tuning in and
thank you to andor
for giving me an opportunity to do this
my name is doug peters i'm a
postdoctoral associate in robert
garcia's lab
at the university of colorado boulder in
the bio frontiers institute
today i'm going to be sharing some of my
recent research
in particular how we've been using
different kinds of light microscopy
to study the spatiotemporal organization
dynamics and function
of virus replication centers during
marine polyamovirus infection
because of the way the slides are laid
out i'm actually going to turn off my
video for
most of the rest of the talk but i will
be with you
live at the end of this to answer
questions
the story i'm going to tell you today is
based on data from these two papers
much of the super resolution 3d sim data
is from this plos pathogens paper that
we published in march
and the live cell microscopy data is
from this paper which was just accepted
for a special issue of viruses
and the special issue is focusing on the
application of advanced imaging to the
study of virus host interactions
i think the submission deadline is
actually at the end of november
so maybe check it out on their website
if you're interested i think it's going
to be a pretty cool issue
so in addition to the data from these
papers i've sprinkled in just a few
pieces of some additional data that are
unpublished
at this point
with that out of the way i'll start with
an outline of how the talk is organized
to help kind of orient ourselves as we
work our way through it
the first will be an introduction to
polyamoviruses
then i'll tell you about my
spatiotemporal analysis of polyamovirus
replication centers
in both wild type and mutant infections
then i'll walk through some general
conclusions
and my working model and some future
directions
i imagine many of you have been thinking
about viruses more in the past year than
you probably ever have before
but i nonetheless want to orient you to
kind of the diversity
of different kinds of viruses and virus
families
viruses can be roughly organized by the
material and polarity of their genomes
be they positive sense single stranded
rna
viruses like coronaviruses and
flaviviruses
or double-stranded dna genomes like
herpes viruses
papilloma viruses and polymoviruses or
really
anything in between today i'll be
talking exclusively about polyomoviruses
which as i mentioned a moment ago have a
double-stranded dna genome
before going into kind of the nitty
gritty detail about these viruses i want
to tell you a little bit more about them
and why we think they're important
the first thing you need to know about
polyanimal viruses or pyvs
is that they have a diverse host range
we've known for decades
that members of the polyamovirus family
can infect a number of different species
including
birds mice rhesus macaque monkeys
and of course humans
these viruses were discovered because of
the diseases that they caused
but as researchers have started looking
for polymer viruses and other animals
they found them infecting many many more
species such as
several sea lion species sea otters
dolphins alpacas
tree shrews and even giant pandas more
recently
analysis of dna sequencing databases
revealed polyomovirus like sequences
associated with several more mammalian
fish and insect species
together this all points to
long-standing co-evolution between
animals and polyamory viruses
and to add another layer of complexity
to all this
there are likely multiple polymorph
viruses that infect each of these
animals
and for an example of this we just need
to look at ourselves
there are 14 known human polymorph
viruses that
infect a diverse range of cell types in
the human body
some human polymor viruses are
ubiquitous in the population and the
chances are pretty good
that everyone listening to this has at
least one polymor virus in their system
right now
we are likely exposed to these viruses
during childhood after which they
cause asymptomatic persistent infections
our immune systems work really hard to
keep infections like these in check
but when the immune system is
compromised in one way or the other
these very common human viruses can
reactivate
so to speak and cause very serious
diseases
okay so now that we've covered some
basic paleovirus epidemiology
let me tell you a little bit about the
virus itself first of all
polymovirus capsids are non-enveloped
meaning
that this viral particle is what the
cell binds in endocytosis is at the
start of infection
there isn't a lipid bilayer or a lipid
layer surrounding
the viral particle as is the case for
viruses like flus
and coronaviruses within this protein
shell is the viral genome
which is composed of about 5300 base
pairs of double-stranded dna
wrapped around 24 nucleosomes that are
co-opted from the host during infection
the genome is organized into early and
late regions
the early region expresses tumor or t
antigen proteins which we're going to
talk a lot more about today
these t antigen proteins permit an
enhanced infection
the late region expresses the structural
capsid proteins vp1 2 and 3.
and finally viral genome replication and
assembly of new viruses occurs in the
host nucleus
so next i want to put these processes of
nuclear replication and virus assembly
in the context of the whole viral life
cycle
the virus first attaches to receptors on
the cell's membrane
which triggers endocytosis the virus
trafficks along microtubules to the
endoplasmic reticulum where the virus
is partially dismantled by er resonant
proteins
the viral genome is then trafficked to
the host nucleus
the viral t antigen proteins are
expressed first shown here in purple
one of these tendonition proteins called
large t
or lt is translocated
to the nucleus and directs viral dna
replication
when replication is underway the
structural proteins start being
expressed shown here in gold
they also translocate to the nucleus
where viral assembly takes place
eventually the nucleus fills up with
virus in the cell lysis releasing
progeny virus to go on and infect other
cells
my work specifically focuses on the
replication
of viral dna in the nucleus so pretty
much everything i want to show you is
taking place in the nucleus
i want to provide a slightly more
detailed model of viral dna replication
for you based on
kind of what we know now as the t
antigen proteins are expressed
replication factors mediate the
amplification of viral genomes
including cellular proteins like dna
polymerases and pcna
as well as the viral large t antigen
protein
which mediates viral replication and is
absolutely required for infection
the dna replication products are
catenated or interlocking circular
genomes
these genomes can't be packaged into
viruses as they are
but cellular dna damage response
proteins such as these
are recruited and mediate the resolution
of discrete
monomeric viral genomes which can then
be encapsulated by the late proteins
vp12 and 3.
this process is relatively consistent
between polyomoviruses
but all the work i'm showing you today
is from mouse or metering polymovirus
which we use as a model for the family
viral replication occurs within these
sub-nuclear domains
termed or called viral replication
centers or vrcs
which are composed of cellular and viral
proteins
we can visualize these structures using
fluorescence microscopy
and on a grand scale i'm interested in
their their organization
and how it relates to infection here i'm
showing the expansion of replication
centers over time
from discrete foci
to large tracts by the end of infection
by labeling
the large t antigen protein shown in red
my work has specifically focused on
these viral replication centers or vrcs
i'm going to wrap up the introduction
with a quick explanation of
of what these studies are going to talk
about and
why we answered these questions or
investigated them
first of all polyamory viruses are
everywhere they persistently infect
humans
as well as many other species viral
replication centers are a critical
aspect of the host pathogen interface
since viral and cellular proteins work
together to accurately and efficiently
replicate viral genomes
by enhancing our understanding of vrcs
we may better understand polyamovirus
infections and diseases
so my overarching questions are how are
replication centers organized in space
and time
and how can that organization teach us
something about polyamovirus infection
so that wraps up the introduction
portion of the talk and now i'm going to
tell you what we've learned about murine
polyamorovirus replication centers using
live cell
and super resolution microscopy
techniques
so in the introduction i showed you
these images
of polymer virus replication centers or
vrcs
in fixed cells and i indicated that vrcs
have different appearances
at different times post infection
they tend to look smaller and more focal
early in infection but if you look later
they tend to be more tract like
throughout the nucleus these kind of
base level observations
suggested to us that vrcs probably
change
in size and shape and possibly number
over time but we really have no way to
visualize
vrc's in living cells to complicate
matters
mirroring polymer virus infections are
not synchronous
meaning that in a population of infected
cells some
cells are further along in the infection
cycle than others
this makes it really difficult to assess
differences in replication centers in
fixed cells
whether you're looking at mutant viruses
or drug treatments or whatever
to address this problem my colleague kim
erickson
and i generated a system that would
allow us to visualize vrcs in living
cells throughout infection
the goal was to investigate these arrows
and the processes we thought they might
represent from vrc formation
to their expansion and merging and
eventually cell lysis and viral release
one of the cellular proteins that
localizes to vrcs
is called replication protein a or rpa
rpa is a heterotrimer composed of 70 32
and 14 kilo dalton subunits that
coats single stranded dna at replication
forks
and dna breaks undergoing repair we
obtained a plasmid from dr
mark wald at the university of iowa that
expresses a human rpa 32 protein
fused to a gfp we generated a mouse
fibroblast cell line
that stably expresses this gfp tagged
rpa 32
to make sure this transgenic and tagged
protein was localizing as it was
supposed to in our mouth cells
we did some characterization experiments
which you can read more about
in the viruses paper but for the sake of
time i'll just tell you that
this gfp rpa construct relocalized to
replication centers over time
it also relocalized to cellular dna
damage over time
the cells were perfectly happy they were
infectable and they produced virus
so this system really gave us a way to
image vrcs in live cells
for the first time here's a field of
infected cells that were imaged from
20 to 50 hours post infection at 10
minute intervals
all the live cell data that i'll show
you today was captured on
andor 888 ultra emccd
in this video clip you'll see several
exhibits several of these cells
exhibit nuclear foci that expand and
merge
over the course of infection before the
cell eventually dies
one of the biggest challenges with these
kind of data is how to analyze them and
distill these observations
into quantitative measurements i'm going
to let this play out again because i
think it looks really cool
so bear with me
okay so i created a matlab script that
quantified gfp rpa 32 relocalization
over time in single cell vignettes
like this this is one uninfected cell
and this is an infected cell
the script quantified a number of
different characteristics but
the percent of signal in vrcs was the
primary metric i used
to quantify rpa relocalization basically
this metric reflects the relocalization
of gfp
rpa signal from the diffuse and dim
nucleoplasm
to dense and bright vrcs
uninfected cells didn't exhibit any rpa
relocalization over time shown here in
orange
whereas our pa in infected cells
relocalized
to vrcs
one of the i mean this was really
exciting to get this system working and
to have a way to analyze them so one of
the first questions we wanted to
investigate was how
the multiplicity of infection or moi
affects vrc formation and expansion
kinetics
for those who aren't familiar with the
terminology the moi
is basically a measure of how much virus
was put on the cells
during infection we found that
vrcs tended to form at earlier times
post-infection
when the moi was higher so here's the
percent of signal in vrcs on the y-axis
and hours post-infection
hpi on the x-axis
individual traces of cells infected with
high
medium and low mois are shown in orange
violet and blue respectively
by 20 hours post infection we observed
many of these high
moi cells with large vrcs whereas many
of these
low fears or low moi cells did not form
replication centers until after 30 hours
post infection
we also found that there is a lot of
variability between cells
as you can see here which is probably
due to the asynchronicity of
polyamovirus infections
to remove the effect of this variable i
aligned the individual traces of each
cell to a threshold
5 shown here by this dotted line
and found that the rpa relocalization
kinetics were actually very consistent
between cells
during this linear phase suggesting
there are limiting factors that may
dictate the rate
of rpa relocalization such as the
availability of
viral dna we will
revisit these live cell assays in a few
minutes when we get to talking
about the mutant viruses but i want to
first dig a little bit deeper into how
these vrcs are organized in the process
of collecting these live cell data i
took some short movies of infected cells
at higher resolutions
these movies revealed that gfp rpa
signal was not
as uniformly distributed as it appeared
at lower resolutions
in fact we resolved several small rpa
foci
within these vrcs
this observation helped prompt a
collaboration with double helix optics
a startup company here in boulder using
super resolution
storm microscopy and this also used an
andor detector
where we confirmed the presence of gfp
rpa foci within replication centers and
this is one nucleus and i'm showing
a max intensity projection through the
whole depth of the nucleus and each of
these little clusters
is one of these rpa foci within a
replication center like this
while this result was really exciting in
and of itself
in a more general sense it suggested
that other vrc components
may not be uniformly distributed so in
other words
there may be areas within vrcs where
different components are concentrated
we've seen hints of this before using
laser scanning confocal microscopy
when imaging large t engine and other
vrc components
in this case phosphoatm and activated
dna damage response kinase in areas like
this
these two proteins clearly occupy a
similar space within the nucleus but the
overlap is
imperfect at the replication center
itself there are regions where either
protein is independent of or at least
much brighter than the other
i wondered if these small spatial
differences could represent functionally
distinct
vrc subdomains i use another kind of
super resolution microscopy called 3d
structured illumination microscopy or
3d sim to investigate this question
before i show you what these images look
like i want to describe the experiment
and how it's different from the data
i've shown you so far
first of all these are wild type cells
not the gfp rpa cells and they're fixed
not alive
i've labeled these cells for endogenous
rpa 32
the viral large t antigen protein and
viral dna
by fluorescent mc2 hybridization or fish
which labels all the viral genomes in
the cell
this is what a typical infected cell
looks like at this time point and i've
zoomed in
on this one vrc
first i saw these rpa foci which was
consistent with the results i showed you
earlier from the transgenic cell line
interestingly the fish signal overlapped
viral dna really well but large t
antigen did not
and so really these results indicated
that murine polyamorovirus replication
centers
are organized into spatially distinct
subdomains
occupied by rpa 32 and large t antigen
i'll be using these two proteins a lot
throughout the talk to mark
these distinct compartments within vrcs
compartmentalization like this has been
observed in other dna viruses but never
polyomoviruses so that was pretty
exciting for us to quantify
the spatial relationships between points
or between proteins
in my 3d sim images i used pearson's
correlation coefficients or pccs
the pcc analysis measures how well the
pixel intensities correlate
between two fluorescent images it is not
a measure of spatial overlap
like other co-localization metrics
instead
pccs measure co-occurrence
when a pixel is bright in channel one
how likely is it to be
also bright in channel two the basis for
this kind of analysis
is that spatial relationships imply
functional relationships so a perfect
correlation of one
would look like this there's a perfect
correlation at each pixel
between the two fluorescence channels a
non-correlation of zero would look
something like this
you can also imagine a perfect
anti-correlation of negative one
that typically indicates exclusion or
repulsion of whatever's in your images
when it comes to analyzing fluorescence
microscopy images this way
thresholding is a critical critical step
in
isolating signal that you want to
analyze
thresholding is important because there
are a lot of pixels especially in these
3d sim images
that don't have any useful or real
information in them
for my analyses i use percentile based
intensity thresholds
which excuse me i'll give an example of
here
this is rpa 32 signal from a single vrc
the white pixels are those that exceed
the threshold
denoted here and the black pixels are
those that do not
exceed the threshold the higher we set
the threshold
the fewer dim background pixels are
included in the analysis
i used this method for all the different
fluorescence labels
in this study but it was especially
useful for separating two different
subsets of rpa 32 signal
dim dim rpa 32
shown in blue here and brighter focal
rpa 32
shown in red here are the results of pcc
analysis for several nuclei
in this experiment here i'm showing the
average pcc values
of large t antigen with each rpa 32
subset
we found that large t engine correlated
best with dim rpa 32
which is consistent with what we see by
eye
we also found that fish labeled viral
dna correlated best
with focal rpa 32
which is also consistent with what we
see by eye
these results confirm spatially distinct
subdomains
are present and occupied by rpa 32 and
large t
antigen after identifying these distinct
vrc subdomains i
analyzed the localization of other vrc
components relative to rpa 32 and large
t
antigen there are many known vrc
components but i focused on
ddr proteins for this study the first
protein is phospho rpa
32 s4s8 which preferentially associates
with damaged dna rather than replication
forks
pcc analysis indicated that phospho rpa
32
correlated best with focal rpa 32
which was consistent with what we
observed in these images
i repeated this process for three other
ddr dna damage response proteins
phosphoatm gamma h2ax
and mre11 which are all indicators of
ddr signaling
they all correlated better with rpa than
with large t antigen
and they each specifically correlated
best with focal rpa 32
indicating that viral dna
in this subdomain may be undergoing
repair in these rpa foci
we hypothesized that if viral dna
in the focal rpa subdomain is undergoing
repair
then viral dna
may be synthesized near large t antigen
to answer this question i used the
thymidine analog
edu which is incorporated into nascent
dna
as it's being synthesized edu can be
conjugated to fluorescent dyes using
[ __ ] chemistry
enabling the visualization of edu
labeled dna
we knew from previous experiments that
edu labels nascent
viral dna within vrcs like this cell
that was pulsed
with edu for 30 minutes prior to being
fixed
i adapted this principle to pulse chase
experiments
where infected cells were given a much
shorter edu pulse usually five minutes
then either fixed immediately or
chased into edu free media before being
fixed at a later time point
in effect the edu pulse labels a
discrete subpopulation of viral dna
and we're imaging that subpopulation at
different times post-synthesis
and in different cells
i did an edu pulse chase experiment like
this and labeled rpa 32 and large t
antigen
and i found that nascent edu labeled
viral dna overlapped very well with
large t antigen
in the chase conditions however edu
labeled viral dna
appeared to dissociate from large t
antigen and relocate
to our relocalized to rpa 32
pcc analysis confirmed the progressive
relocalization
of edu labeled viral dna from large t
engine
oops large t antigen to focal rpa 32.
these results indicated that large t
antigen and focal rpa 32
subdomains are spatially and
functionally distinct
so just to kind of bring this all
together to some conclusions about the
wild type replication centers
we generated stable cell lines
expressing a gfp
rpa 32 and visualized vrc dynamics over
time using live cell fluorescence
microscopy
we found that rpa relocalization
kinetics were consistent between cells
despite the asynchronicity of formation
suggesting there may be limiting factors
that dictate the rate
of rpa relocalization and that's
something we're looking into currently
rpa 32 and large t antigen are organized
into spatially and functionally distinct
subdomains
and the replication associated subdomain
that we found
was occupied by a large t antigen and
mason viral dna
and there is a repair associated
subdomain occupied by focal rpa 32
ddr proteins and chaste viral dna
so to bring this back to this model of
polymorphis genome
replication my results indicated that
these processes
viral dna replication and
genome resolution are likely occurring
in separate vrc subdomains
the first may be occupied by these
replication-associated proteins
and nascent viral dna and the second
occupied by these dna repair associated
proteins
that can resolve viral dna intermediates
into monomeric
packageable genomes
all of the experiments in this section
were done using wild type virus but
i'm going to next share what we learned
about how the viral t antigen proteins
contribute to viral dna replication by
studying
mutant viruses to study the roles of
individual t
antigen proteins i use mutant myriad
polymoviruses
called 808 and ng18
which lack expression of one or more t
antigen protein
as i mentioned way back in the
introduction marine polymer viruses
expressed three t
antigen proteins large t middle t and
small t
the 808 a virus only expressed as large
t and small t
and the n g 18 virus only expresses
large t
antigen by subtraction any difference
between
808 a and ng18 can be attributed to the
activity of small t
antigen early work
from the 1980s with these viruses
indicated that
ng18 infections only replicate about 10
percent as much viral dna
as wild type or 808 infections
indicating small t
contributes to efficient viral dna
replication
i repeated a similar experiment using
qpcr
and got pretty similar results when a
previous graduate student katie heiser
visualized viral replication centers
during each of these infections she
found that ng-18
brcs were always smaller than wild type
or 808 avrcs
combined these results suggest that vrc
morphology
or size depends on the degree of viral
dna replication
it's unclear from these experiments
though how exactly replication centers
are
different during ng18 infection
and how small tanagin contributes to
viral dna replication
before i tell you what i've done to help
answer these questions i first want to
tell you what we know about small t
the characteristic function of small t
is the modulation of protein phosphatase
2a
or pp2a pp2a is an important regulator
of the cell cycle and the dna damage
response by regulating protein
phosphorylation
pp2a typically exists as a heterotrimer
there's an a scaffold subunit
ac catalytic subunit and a b regulatory
subunit
small t mimics a b regulatory subunit
directing pp2a activity towards some
substrates and away from others
to understand how small t relates to
vrcs and vrc expansion
i analyze these mutant mirroring
polyamor viruses
using live cell microscopy of gfp rpa 32
cells
so just to refresh this is what a wild
type and felt infected cell looks like
you'll see vrcs form and expand until
the cell eventually dies
808 a infected cells look similar
to wild type but
brcs don't appear to expand after they
form
i quantified these data in the same way
i showed you earlier
by quantifying the percent of signal in
vrcs
over time i found that wild type and 808
a
were very similar on average but ng18
was significantly different
another mutant ng59 shown in violet
was similar to ng18 and it also only
expresses large t antigen
to get a better understanding of how the
ng18 vrcs were different
i quantified other characteristics that
could result
in this defect i'm not going to show
the data for this point in particular
because it wasn't very interesting
but i quantified the number of
replication centers in each cell
at this threshold
and there was no difference between
conditions
each virus had about 20 replication
centers per cell plus or minus about six
however we did find that the percentage
of nuclear area occupied
by replication centers was lower in ng18
and ng59
infected cells indicating that small t
is required for vrc expansion
furthermore we found that the average
density of gfp signal within replication
centers tended to be lower
in ng18 and ng59 infected cells
suggesting those vrcs may harbor less
viral dna than wild type or 808-a vrcs
these results were consistent with
previous studies showing mutants lacking
small t
replicate far less viral dna during
infection
we believe this live cell microscopy
system recapitulated those results
and opens the door for more temporal
studies
showing mutants or sorry more temporal
analyses
using other lifestyle markers in
combination
for the rest of the talk though i'm
going to be switching back to the super
resolution 3d sim
images of fixed cells so far i've shown
you that ng18
does not replicate viral dna very well
and ng18 vrcs don't expand very much
after forming
i next analyzed how small t engine
contributes to viral dna relocalization
similar to wild type ng-18 brcs
exhibited
organization of focal rpa-32 and large
t-antigen into distinct subdomains
and nascent edu-labeled viral dna
overlapped with large t antigen in the
pulse chase conditions however
i did not observe the same level of
viral dna relocalization as we observed
in wild-type vrcs
here's the pcc analysis of ng18 infected
cells in orange compared to wild type
infected cells in gray
it indicated large t and ng-18 viral dna
did not dissociate as much
over the 60-minute chase and
viral dna relocation to focal rpa 32
was delayed in ng-18 infected cells
these results indicated that small t is
required for
efficient viral dna relocalization after
synthesis
i also calculated the pcc values for
large t antigen and rpa 32 subsets in
ng18 infected cells compared to wild
type i detected a significant increase
in the correlation of large t
and dim rpa 32 this implies there's more
rpa
at ng18 viral dna replication forks
which
is a hallmark of replication stress this
result hinted
that small t may contribute to viral dna
sorry
to vrc organization
to test this idea i localized the same
ddr
proteins as i showed earlier phosphor
rpa
our phosphoatm gamma h2ax and
mra11 during ng18 infection he compared
the results to wild-type vrcs
in wild-type vrcs these proteins all
preferentially correlated with the focal
rpa-32 subdomain
but in ng-18 vrc's hyper-phosphorylated
32 exhibited reversed correlations it
correlated worse with focal rpa 32
and much better with large t antigen
phospho phosphoatm the ddr kinase
shifted slightly away from focal rpa-32
but unexpectedly i also observed regions
of vrc
adjacent labeling that were not present
in wild-type infection
gamma h2ax the damage associated histone
only shifted localization very modestly
within vrcs
but i again observed regions of vrc
adjacent signal
mre 11 the component of the mrn complex
that detects double-stranded dna breaks
was the only protein that didn't change
localization between viruses
these data indicate that small t engine
contributes to viral replications that
center organization
and that ddr signaling may be different
between wild type and ng18
infections
alright so our takeaways from this
mutant analysis section
first of all rpa relocalization rate
in wild type and 808 a vrcs were the
same
viral dna relocalization in wild type
and 808 vrcs was also the same
small t antigen contributes to vrc
expansion
viral dna relocalization and vrc
organization
ng18 vrcs did not expand after formation
in the gfp rpa cells ng18 viral dna
also did not efficiently relocalize from
large t
to rpa 32 subdomains some ddr proteins
were localized differently
in the ng-18 infected cells
so i'm going to talk about what these
results mean in a minute
um so i'm going to talk through these
overall conclusions
my working model and finally some future
directions
i want these conclusions to be the big
picture takeaways from this presentation
first of all polyamovirus replication
centers are dynamic
complex nuclear domains live cell
microscopy allowed us to study how these
replication centers change over time in
single cells
super resolution microscopy resolved the
compartmentalization
of vrc components into subdomains that
were spatially and functionally distinct
small t antigen is critical for the
accurate and efficient replication of
polyamovirus genomes
we showed by live cell microscopy that
ng-18 vrcs do not expand after formation
and super-resolution microscopy exposed
differences
in viral dna relocalization after
synthesis
and the organization of ddr proteins
within ng18 vrcs
finally image analysis can yield more
information
from fluorescence microscopy images than
our eyes can alone
so i want to bring us back to this model
one more time my results indicated
that viral dna replication and genome
resolution are likely occurring in
separate subdomains within vrcs
my results also indicated a small t
antigen contributes to
the spatial and temporal organization of
these processes
but how exactly might that here is my
current working model
in polyamovirus replication centers
there are many phosphorylated proteins
including those i've shown images of
today the phosphorylation states of
these proteins
dictate their function in dna
replication and repair
this phosphorylation state is in turn
regulated by cellular phosphatases like
pp2a
in wild-type infection small t
could be targeting pp2a phosphatase
activity in such a way that permits
robust and accurate replication of
monomeric viral genomes in infections
lacking small t
however the endogenous pp2a activity
could be targeted differently resulting
in a different set of phosphor proteins
and reduced viral dna accumulation my
results showed
that these phosphor proteins are still
present in the absence of small t
but their relocalization indicates ddr
signaling is also different
i'll be investigating this model in more
depth
currently actually all right
that leads us to the future directions
these are some questions that
have stemmed from the work i showed you
today and they're things that
are currently being investigated in the
lab
first of all how do genetic and chemical
perturbations affect
vrc composition organization and
function
in other words how can we interrupt
these processes of
viral dna replication and genome
resolution and how does it affect
replication centers in a way that we can
observe by microscopy
we've done a little bit of this with
hydroxyurea which depletes dntps
and inhibits replication
installs replication forks and
we found that it pretty dramatically
changes the way replication centers look
and this work is shown in the plus
pathogens paper
but i didn't have time to show it today
are there other vrc subdomains so i
showed you a replication associated sub
domain and a repair associated subdomain
but we think there may also be a
subdomain associated with viral gene
transcription where transcription
machinery
localizes as well
as viral genome chromatization so
the viral dna has to be chromatinized by
the host's nucleosomes prior to
encapsulation
and there's a lot of cellular machinery
that's involved in that process and we
think there may be a subdomain
associated with it
where does viral dna localize after rpa
foci
so the edu pulse chase experiments i
showed you today
only went as far as these this genome
resolution step we think
we don't know at this point where viral
dna
localizes after it leaves rpa foci
so we're working on pushing that pulse
chase experiment
further down the pipeline to see where
viral dna localizes
and with what proteins and it associates
what else can we learn about vrc
subdomains from microscopy
all of the information i showed you
today is based on kind of
nuclear like whole nucleus analysis
and i'm interested in building new tools
to improve the resolution of our
analysis
and finally what other proteins are
associated with replication centers
during infection so i showed you a
handful of proteins today
there are many more associated with
replication centers
and it'll be interesting to see which
ones
associate with viral dna at different
times post synthesis
and we're also using a biochemical
technique
called ipond to identify um
proteins associated with replication
centers that we didn't even know were
there
so kind of building a roadmap for how
this whole process
works to touch on one of those points
really quickly i just want to talk about
how we're
working on improving the resolution of
image analysis so as i just said
previous analyses of all the live cell
and super resolution images are based on
whole nuclei
and a new tool that is in development
currently will hopefully let us dig
deeper by automatically identifying and
analyzing
individual replication centers within
cells
this has been a technically challenging
aspect of image analysis
because as i've shown you today these
replication centers
are very dynamic they sometimes are very
close to each other they grow
they expand they merge they really
change over time
and so building a tool to
automatically identify them in all their
diversity in space and time
has been challenging but we're hoping
that
by analyzing them individually we can
increase
the granularity of the information we
get from these microscopy data
each replication center can be analyzed
individually
to quantify the co-localization of
different proteins the relative volume
of different
sub-domains intensity correlations
things like that
so that's kind of an exciting thing that
i i've been working on
yeah so just a big thank you to all of
you for listening
this is a really fun opportunity to
share my research with such
a big and global group of people thank
you to andor for setting it up
and lab roots for hosting it
thank you to the garcia lab for
everything
the two light microscopy core facilities
where i do all of this work
they're run by dr james orth and dr joe
dragovon and
they really keep these microscopes up
and running in good condition
this work is all supported by nih grants
and
with that i would be happy to take
questions thank you you doug
hello i am dr alan mullen product
specialist for microsoft cameras at
andor technology
and in the last couple of slides of this
presentation
i wanted to briefly outline some of the
imaging solutions that andor provide for
virology experiments this covers
a range of high sensitivity cameras
confocal systems which combine multiple
imaging techniques within the one system
and of course we also have the mrs
software which is a powerful tool for
visualization and analysis
but i really just want to focus on the
camera side of this
as we know fluorescence microscopy is a
really powerful technique
across all of cell biology
applications but for virology
it's it's much more difficult viruses of
course are much smaller which causes a
lot of problems
since they are well below the
limit of diffraction making light
microscopy very difficult to see what's
just going
on beneath that resolution limit
size also can make it quite difficult in
terms of
effective labeling of those components
of the virus capsid
and so on and lastly of course we have a
sort of a background or a context of
biosafety of how we handle whatever
virus or model that we're working with
but thankfully there's a range of
microscopy techniques which
have really allowed us to progress
fluorescence microscopy for gaining
further insight
into the virus infectious cycle
and understanding more about the virus
and whose cell interactions as
doug has described earlier so
different techniques of course will have
their different advantages
um techniques like turf are very useful
for studying events and high resolution
but only in a small depth
of less than 100 nanometers making it
effective for events close to the cell
membrane
3d sim as doug has described along with
other super resolution techniques such
as storm and
palm allow much improved resolution
so it allows us to get a much better
idea of
how components of the virus label
components of the virus
and of the host cells are localized
together
during the infectious cycle also as part
of this
beyond the techniques there's been
developments in labeling strategies of
how we label
viruses and including genetically
encoded
dyes and then also um not quite so much
but
um also quantum dots as well as an
alternative strategy
and really driving or really
helping to allow everything
to go ahead um
we need to have high sensitivity
detectors and we see
emccd and sc most cameras playing a role
in this
on the right hand side we can see an
example of some
imaging compared to wide field above and
you can see
an improvement in resolution between
those two
methods
for typical cell imaging applications
and also for
say some high throughput pcr based
screening we can use scmos cameras
because these are very fast sensitive
for what we need them to do
and also allow us to have a very wide
field of view
but whenever we start looking at
experiments where we're trying to
look at individual virus particles
and how they interact with um
intracellular structures and features
within the cell for example
the signals involved are inherently very
weak so we need to get the most
sensitive detector that we can
and the most sensitive cameras that we
have available
are what's called emccd technology
cameras
and what's important in these is that
they have
electron multiplication
circuitry within them and it's unique to
this
kind of camera and this allows them to
boost
the incoming signal manifold
so that before the camera reads out it
is
much higher than the background level so
even for
small numbers of photons very low levels
of light
these cameras are still effective
whereas
sc mos camera as above here as you can
see in the upper image that you can't
see
any signal at all so
for that reason they're widely used
still and signal molecule physics
applications and of course also for
uh virology and wider
microbiology of bacteria as well
and in terms of these cameras it has
been the exxon emc ccd
cameras that for many years have been
used and
over the time these have been refined
reaching the
current models which there's an exxon
ultra model which is
the most sensitive emccd camera
available
and then there is also an exxon life
camera which
allows people to use emccd technology
at a lower price point because obviously
this
exclusive technology costs more
than any sc mos camera would typically
do
some of the main points about the exxon
am ccd cameras
are about this the sensitivity that they
can provide which is
achieved through 95 quantum efficiency
which means that
95 percent of the photons which hits
that hit that sensor
are converted into an electronic signal
and of course the em
gain that's unique to these cameras that
i mentioned
um the exxon cameras are also deep cool
to minus 100 degrees c so this means
that you can achieve the lowest
possible noise and the sensors are
enclosed in a permanent
vacuum seal for reliability and to allow
that deep cooling
without issues to do with condensation
there's a range of sensor models and
both the
ultra and the lower cost life ranges
and these are really to do with the
sizes of the sensors
that you can have so the full details
and those specifications are
available on the specification sheet
if we look at how the exon has been used
in
virology experiments we can break this
down
by really a nato's head of viruses
and we can see that this ties in with
the clinical significance of these
viruses so it would be the usual
suspects of things such as hiv
influenza a hepatitis c
and more recently we can of course we
can see corona
forests as well appearing in the last
number of years
and by application type as well we can
see the
types of application or technique rather
that it has been
used and so as we talked about single
molecule
localization based super resolution sim
as uh doug has described here um earlier
and turf and normal confocal as well
with a few other techniques
um starting to creep in as well and
finally we can also look at what aspect
of the virus infectious cycle has been
studied
with these cameras and we can see those
covers of the events of the
virus cycle
as well as the
development of antiviral drug treatments
and
vaccines as well
in the last number of years we have seen
a new generation of
scmos cameras called back illuminated
cmos and
what these do is these
build upon the strengths of scmos
cameras which is it's high speed and
large fields of view
and they do this by boosting that
quantum efficiency so they're more
efficient
at converting the signals into
an electrical signal an example of this
would be our
android sonar cmos cameras range
so if we briefly compare these
if we look at this signal-to-noise ratio
plot
and we can compare how well these
cameras do it's
different amounts of light in terms of
photons per
pixel and signal to noise with a better
signal to noise ratio giving better
performance
we can see that this emccd trace is down
here
so the very lowest end of the scale we
can see that emccd
is providing a better signal-to-noise
ratio and is therefore more suitable for
applications within that area and then
if we look at the back illuminated scmos
cameras
their profile is is higher up
so we can still see that where we see
virology studies
uh typically being situated the emccd
cameras
would still overall be the
option to choose however back
illuminated sc mos cameras
you do see some overlap potentially for
those
so if we have enough signal we can take
advantage of those
faster scmos cameras and the wider
fields of view so we can see more of a
sample
and more of what's happening within the
cell
so that means that the it is a possible
alternative to consider
however for these most challenging
applications where we're looking at
live uh virus tracking studies
and looking at high magnification
and very low signals it still remains it
sees em ccd cameras like the exxon
which would be the detectors of choice
perhaps one of the downsides of super
resolution techniques
is the highly specialized requirements
some of them have so you can end up with
having some quite complex setups
um so just to point out an alternative
solution
that can suit some people is through
using technique called surf
and this allows you to boost the
resolution on a normal microscope
in a number of modalities such as wide
field or turf
simply by using this approach and this
approach is
surf as i mentioned is based on
radio fluctuations that occur within
fluorophores
and by using gpu based processing
over a number of very short exposure
frames of your image you can build up
spatial and temporal
information about the fluctuations of
those fluorophores
and then localize that to
allow for a much higher resolution and
for using this technique that you can
achieve
between 100 and 120 nanometers of
resolution
so probably equivalent to what you would
get from sim
and this can be using normal
fluorophores
and crucially can use low illumination
intensities
and this technique has been used for
many
uh studies looking at the intracellular
trafficking and
the effects of localization of
components within the within cells
and a variation of this is called
surfstream plus
which is an option is an optimized
real-time version of
the surf principle and that is
an option that's available exclusively
for free android technology
and is available on selected and or
cameras
so if you want to find out a bit more
about the products covered and
some of the other ones that we didn't
get time to please go to
the andor website to find out more
there's a lot of other more educational
information
on there which looks at a range of
different things such as
the different types of techniques that
are used for virology studies
and how the different
techniques provide advantages for
looking at different aspects of the
virus cycle
and lastly thanks very much to doug for
the presentation today
and for everybody for joining us thank
you
thank you dr peters and dr mullen for
your informative presentations
so we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
and we will answer as many questions as
we have time for
so let's get started with our first one
um
dr paters it looks like this one is for
you and it is a two-part question
what is the earliest time post-infection
that you have followed the vrcs
and the second part is what is the
homology between
rpa human and mouse and you use the
human correct
yeah those are good questions um so
as far as how early we've imaged them
i have imaged them as early as two hours
post-infection and imaged them
out a couple of days on the spinning
disc confocal
actually uh typically we don't see
replication centers forming until kind
of mid
20-ish hours post-infection but as i
showed
during the talk at higher mois we can
push that up and sometimes we see cells
like
12 hours post infection that have
replication centers already
for the second part of the question yes
we did use the human
i think the amino acid percent identity
for rpa 32 is something around 90
percent
so they're pretty highly related that
dna binding domain is
pretty much identical and all of the
phosphorylation
sites on the n-terminus of rpa 32 are
also
the same wonderful that looks like we
have time for
one more question so we'll move on to
our last one great talk dr peters
you showed that there's a transition
from catenated circular v dna
that is decaffeinated prior to following
steps of the viral cycle
can you please give some further insight
about this step of transition
and what is known about the requirement
of decantination
also if there also is the decantination
step
really upstream from really upstream
excuse me
from chromatinization yeah those are
good questions
uh so the decatenation step
um from what
i recall so these these dna damage were
dna damage response proteins kind of
help mediate
the cairns intermediate that forms
on the opposite end of the of the viral
genome from the origin
of replication and this resolution step
is thought to be required for packaging
of discrete viral genomes
i know that i'm trying to think of a way
to answer
the second part of the question so there
are
there are situations where you get
rolling circle replication of the viral
genome instead of these catenated viral
genomes and those cannot be packaged um
but as far as an inhibitor that
or some sort of perturbation that
affects the actual resolution
i i haven't heard of it but that's that
would be an interesting thing to pursue
and is this step upstream from
chromatization
um that is also something that we're
looking into we
we don't know when these viral genomes
are chromatinized
it would be really interesting to see
where that machinery localizes and
that's actually something
that we've been talking about doing so
yeah i think those are really good
questions and
and stuff that we're looking forward to
investigating soon
wonderful thank you again dr peters and
dr mullen um
do either of you have final comments for
our audience
um thank you all for listening and i
will try to answer some of these
questions um
after this and i'll reach out and
contact you
yep that's it uh thanks to everybody for
listening today and
we'll try and get back to anybody who
answered us or asked us any questions
that we haven't been able to get time to
answer
thank you wonderful before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
i know we didn't have a ton of time but
as our speaker said
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
peters and dr mullen for the
for their time today and their important
research we would also like to thank
labberts and our sponsor andor
for underwriting today's educational
webcast you can view the webinar on
demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again next
time
bye-bye
you